hey guys this is John welcome back to
spectrum I'm real quick I just want to
let you know we have a new episode of
our podcast radical empathy
it features an interview with Calvin who
is in this episode of spectrum we talked
about what it was like to grow up in a
polygamous family and we also kind of
just dive into the larger idea of mental
caves and what it's like to leave those
caves I know you have some time on your
hands in this kind of new coronavirus
reality so sit down put in some earbuds
give it a listen very strange time in
the world right now but we appreciate
you supporting our content stay safe out
there thank you I thought the world I
thought the world outside was the evil
place and we were the ones that were the
good ones the number of students are in
my classroom are in old language a
couple thousand years ago disciples we
thought we were joining a movement to
make the world better when are you gonna
wake up with this precious opportunity
come to view what happened to me is a
viral mimetic infection what'd you call
it a cult you really know what a coldie
is but I know I don't have one I grew up
as a Mormon Fundamentalist I was in it
for 30 years I have one dad for moms and
I'm one of 45 kids
my parents and I had some difficulty I
was sent away to a Southern Baptist than
a mentalist reform school it was a very
extreme environment
I was born into the Tony and Susan
allama Christian foundation after
realizing that I was lied to my whole
life I needed to escape
I was in a Gurdjieff group for a little
over 15 years I got into and I was 22
right out of college when I was 22 I got
involved in a meditation group the Guru
turned out to be very negative and
narcissistic and I was in for 22 years
[Music]
we didn't call it a cult I certainly
didn't join a cult no not at all I knew
it was unorthodox so I knew it wasn't
mainstream well mine was called the
reform school so it was labeled
something quite different right
mine was labeled a Foundation a
Christian foundation yeah and mine was
an extension of artistic training or
training I just thought it was an
outgrowth of that when you're in it like
it's like it's invisible you don't lose
your life I mean you a big part of it
yeah when you're born in it and that's
all you've done I mean I still don't use
that the strong language of a cult I
don't think it's productive for the
people that are there because they get
defensive but yeah certainly if you're
in it and it's what you're doing in your
day to day I think they truly do believe
that this is a better way we truly are
God's people or we truly are doing
something good in the world and I think
that's one of the reasons you can get in
those mental thought traps I think it's
really easy to blanket state say that
someone is quote-unquote brainwashed the
deepest wind that could come from this
is empathy maybe for people in it but
also for the people outside of it too
three two one wait I I'm wrong Karen I'm
sorry I thought I was on the other let
me go over here why are you moving
because I was forcibly but into the
place that I was that well maybe I'm
wrong maybe I should be here I guess cuz
I I walked in the door
I don't think anyone joins a cult really
on purpose right then that is so true
so I think yes I volunteered but it
wasn't what I thought it was and so when
I got into I think with a lot of people
it's like they don't tell you everything
you don't know what you're doing yet and
so yeah you you willingly start
something but you don't call it a call I
lived in New York City but I was in LA
for only six months but you could not
walk down the street without a Hari
Krishna without a Mooney without a
Scientologist and I was really curious
so I went to all of them so this one
seemed more intellectually rigorous it
seemed connected to the studying I was
doing and then when I was 19 so it was
about two or three years before I took
acid so that's why I was so curious and
I was so confident that I could question
popular culture but I was very much I
was really young and from Michigan so
what do I know about these so for me for
my experience I would say my parents had
absolutely no idea the experience I was
going to experience and they voluntarily
placed me there however I didn't know I
was surprised as we drove up in the
eight-foot fence with a you know was
electrified barbed wire you know and so
it was extreme for me how old were you I
was 17 years old it was the day after my
17th birthday because of bad contact is
a key thing you know there's a lot of
dysfunction in my house and you know I
acted out because of it I had been
molested by an outside source and so I
was just trying to negotiate childhood
you know and my parents really didn't
know what to do with me my parents had
no idea the abuses that took place when
I got out of there I was afraid of the
world I was afraid of people I started
my nonprofit to help adults who were
subject to this type of abuse as
children
I had about 300 siblings that were
anywhere from you know ten years younger
than me to ten years older than me we
knew each other inside and out I grew up
in Arkansas and a 300 acre compound with
horses you know ponies cows peach
orchards it was awesome it was a good
time when you have 44 brothers and
sisters and you're all living in the
same house it's the best of times you
have your brother since your best
friends that are brothers and sisters
and having four moms I think from my
experience I'll speak for me I know I
can't speak for other people here it was
96 percent freaking awesome it's really
easy to just poopoo on it and say every
single experience I ever had was
absolutely horrible and I think it's a
it's a point to own that's actually the
hardest thing to separate yeah it's like
you don't want to throw the baby out
it's your life right you know to say my
life was a waste you know so how do you
find how do you how do you pick out the
gold yes so I have a different
experience yeah obviously I was out
locked in the environment I was not able
to go and so I had no choice in the
matter and it was horribly abusive I was
locked in a closet
I was demeaned belittled there was sleep
deprivation food deprivation when I came
out of there I was so broken and in when
kids get taken to these places that are
extreme environments this is what
happens mine I was also locked in on a
compound but we were surrounded by
forests there wasn't anywhere to go
well yeah most of these places are
isolated and we also had a system where
everyone reported on each other we'd
also lived in constant fear of being
ratted on but the Bible was what was
used as the that's the gauge to tell you
and beatings forced fastings yes how
could you I mean so in your mind
rationalizing the good times that you
had would to the extreme times I
understand I know because those times
were so bad but they were not it was
what it was was what I was used to yeah
it's all I knew I thought the world I
thought the world outside was the evil
place and we were the ones that were the
good ones I'm here to not only tell my
story as much as I can but also let the
world know that the trauma that cults
can inflict on their members that
there's a life afterwards yeah
I'll give it to them yeah I think it
started out as good that someone yeah
it's somewhat that's why we're here
that's why we're just a little bit agree
yeah I got to move so I'm I'm moving
because when we were in the group we
thought the intentions were good but
when I got out I learned that they had
criminal records and that there they had
motives that had nothing to do with what
they claimed they were I'll be over
there yeah because there's a human
element in that all humans err and so I
got to give it to them that they
probably wanted to improve their
personal lives and I don't see being
selfish as bad as long as it's not
stepping over and hurting other people
to get to those desired ends I think I'm
going to move over here the trouble teen
industry is an industry that has secular
programs wilderness boot camps sorting
schools
rehabilitation centers the idea is you
send your kid to this place to get fixed
it's a million dollar industry and Utah
alone and so I don't think when people
start these things it's about the child
I think it's about the money I think
it's important to clarify if anybody
searches Mormon fundamentalism that why
I'm not on the exact opposite end is
that there are different sects of Mormon
fundamentalism like if I was part of
Warren Jeffs group that infinite he's in
jail for life like
I would be clear over there the people
that I know I think they actually
believed it and so my thing is I think
they were sincere but the ultimate
conclusion I came to is just because
you're sincere doesn't mean you can't be
sincerely wrong when I left my mind was
more with all those people who they got
an elevated social status they would
travel around the world they were
treated like royalty and so if they ever
left the group or questioned they would
lose this like privileged life they were
having so it wasn't just the leader it's
almost like he exported his own
selfishness that is such a good point in
might in my case I was I was born into
the group and I was raised by my cult
leaders and used as an example of how to
be and whenever a child did something
wrong it was compared to me it would
Benjy have done this and the child would
usually say no okay well then give him
40 swats when someone tries to use a
child as leverage against other people
and to manipulate a child to do their
bidding it shows their true intentions
it shows that they are not
well-intentioned when you're young and
something seems like a good idea or
mindfulness you want to throw your whole
shoulder into it and then you don't
realize that there are a lot of other
maybe older people a little bit older
than you that will completely hijack
your essence
I wasn't manipulated as a child so I
kind of want to step back maybe to like
somewhat a I'm like in between here and
there but in reality I feel bad but I
didn't I wasn't a consenting adult the
IMP I wasn't an adult and I was made to
do these things yeah
and they haunt me to this day because I
was leveling up in the system right I
had been broken and so I bought that
what they were selling and so I became
what they called a helper it was a
tragic experience where these people
tried to commit suicide right in front
of me and I had to kind of save them and
there was no medical attention I was
programmed to do these things rights
they conditioned me to have these
responses but I still regret them to
regret it I think that's kind of how I
feel a little bit because the things
that I usually don't like the word
regret because I don't think it it's
productive to be so stuck in the past
but the things the the negative feelings
that came up in me what made me come
over here to agree is there were things
that I was complicit to that I witnessed
that I thought was the right thing but
there was something inside of me in
those moments that I was like this
should not be right like there's the
piece of me now that's like man why
don't you stand up and say something or
do something but when you're in it when
you're there you don't you don't see it
and I think that's part of the almost
the healing process that you have to
have empathy for that version of
yourself like hey you didn't know any
better the things I regret when I look
back on it and I've asked myself this
question before it's why I didn't get
out sooner another thing was not warning
other people of what happened to me I
didn't tell some of my brothers what had
happened to me sexual abuse with this
teacher there were moments when I was
like I recognize that his role trumped
all my friends my family everything like
I have to promise with him and I would
tell anybody right so I really regret
the heads I gave them so much power the
general misconception I I think is that
people don't believe it could happen to
them or they don't understand how it
happened
and people don't see how the cult
pyridine is everywhere there's small
cults just in your office
at that time anyone who was gay male or
female was not allowed to be in the
group so for about 10 years this guy was
able to keep the straight men quiet in
other words our husbands and he would
quietly giving our husbands [ __ ] and
then women and and those of us that
didn't know we're kind of thrown for a
loop when one of the young men to whom
he'd been doing this went to the San
Francisco Chronicle and made a lawsuit
and there were headlines so here you are
going along your feelings about this man
do you care for him I'm on neutral terms
with him I'm not on bad terms I'm not
well if I saw him on the street he
wouldn't be angry with me um I I think I
am angry with him yeah which makes you
not about it wasn't that the question no
I think both of those are correct and I
just want to say for this today right
now is the first time I've ever spoken
out publicly about the cult leader in my
group was marrying eight-year-old girls
and using the Bible to justify saying
Mary the mother of Jesus was a teenager
and that's justification for him to then
give an eight-year-old estrogen to
induce their period so that they would
be justified as a woman I am NOT on good
terms with them and their group still
goes on the reason I'm not on the best
terms with the leaders in my church is I
did so very publicly there was one time
in particularly where one of the church
leaders kind of reprimanded me on one of
my Facebook post saying that I sounded
judgmental I'm my head I remember
thinking I haven't even been in this
what and you think you can tell me what
to do and I was like this guy can go
[ __ ] himself and then I felt all of this
fear come up because yours taught your
entire life that these people are God's
people they're God's prophets so you
don't say anything and I felt so much
fear and I was like
holy this is so weird and so I commented
back and said thanks for the comment but
you can go [ __ ] yourself with love
Calvin Woon
God not my most honest answers is here
in terms of worldly tremendous worldly
experience that I don't think I would
have gotten so I have yet I just grew so
much I mean I used to think I was
growing in one week I would grow a year
but I also learned things I never would
have done myself
like I learned how to dance and learn
how to do massage I learned how did you
know all these different amazing things
for me it was it was good in spite of
the experience I have grown and I'm able
to help people and mentor them and raise
awareness about this abuse because I
went through it but I wouldn't say I was
a better person because of it but in
spite of it there are little pieces of
cults in all things that we don't see
one of my favorite guilty pleasures is
honestly going to YouTube and watching
Flat Earth videos it's so obvious and
you can see the mental traps but here's
the thing we all have so many of those
mental traps the same people that are
pointing and saying oh I can't believe
those people believe that or do that
thing they do it in some other way where
we just believe something because it's
all we've ever believed the reason I'm
not in strongly agree is because you can
see right here there are different kinds
of cult experiences right you guys had
some really really extremely hard ones
you were born into it you had dark dark
experiences we had these other kind of
spiritual dark and light experiences you
know my generation is culture how do you
define the word cold it's right you
define it so that's why I'm here because
I think there's a lot of things that
just aren't cults well I think and the
question was are they all around us and
I think absolutely they are I mean close
is a very strong word and when I talk
about my experience I say cult-like
because you know some people wouldn't
define our experience my experience as
that I I went into a high Chi place just
on the street in Seattle these guys
started using
cult technique manipulation practices to
recruit me it wasn't until I went to
Wikipedia and looked him up right so you
have the education you're able to hear
him a thousand bucks but you were able
to I didn't know but it was close but
that's a good point it was close
eighty in the 80s and 90s we didn't have
the internet we can now I say you're
lazy you're lazy
yes airily even in even in the
boardrooms of the corporations that that
make our airplanes and make our coffee
there is a cult leader at the top I
don't care what anyone says
it's we're still a pyramid Society and
that's why I'm over here because they're
everywhere some of them are dangerous
and some of them aren't
[Applause]
[Music]
and this with you